[Music]
hello and welcome to marshall matters
with me winston marshall at the
spectator offices in
london in this series i've been
exploring freedom of expression in the
creative industries and today i'm joined
by american lo-fi legend ariel pink
ariel has collaborated with the likes of
miley cyrus azealia banks
and has
quite a remarkable music career which
last year
took rather
a surprising turn
as a consequence
of ariel attending the january 6th trump
rally he's been very clear to say not
the capitol hill storming that happened
afterwards
ariel thank you so much for joining me
today thank you winston
happy to be here
you lost really
everything um
in in attending
the trump rally you had
uh over 130 articles
uh besmirching you uh you were dropped
from your record label by text message
um
no less uh you had
sexual abuse accusations
you just had it all coming at you can
you take us to that day and and tell us
your sort of side of the story of that
of that experience yeah uh i'm happy to
um
it was a little field trip uh you know
that was uh
that i had sort of planned last minute
with uh with my friend john and uh
we arrived in dc like uh
like countless others um
to attend the trump rally
and uh that was at the white house lawn
to go see
trump sort of say his final words i
guess we don't have
a fair media anymore
there was there's no there wasn't an
expectation at least not on my part that
like you know anything was going to
be
changed in the
electoral count or anything like that i
mean that mike pence had yet had not
declared
the count yet so
so that was supposed to happen on that
day and i suppose uh you know the
ongoing narrative you know argument on
the left side is uh
that you know
people that were in attendance in
washington dc that day that were on that
were there for trump
were
there to
impede that process as far as i knew
that wasn't the case i mean i didn't
think that there was there was the stop
the steel rally there were all these
different uh
groups of people that were that were
protesting but you know people protest
it was a totally authorized event the
the uh
there were there were licenses and
clearances
for all these people
so i thought that you know when i when i
attended the
white house uh
lawn
you know there was a there was a lot of
people in the streets obviously but
there was a
you know there was like a security
uh kiosk and then you had to go through
a line it was like going to
to concert you know it was it was really
it was official there was security so
there was nothing untoward about it it
felt developed very organic and very
very
very it was really really kind of uh
uplifting you know it's predominantly
white i would say i would say there's a
big contingent of white people but i
think that that's probably going to be
the case
for most uh political rallies in the ego
do that's a big trick to do why were you
there because you were interested and
curious to see what was going on
or were you
going as a supporter of trump i'm i've
been always been very very
loud about my
my thoughts on trump i mean i really i i
was very supportive of him i thought he
was you know
i thought he did a very good job for a
person that wasn't supposed to be there
so
when i say that it wasn't supposed to be
there i mean i mean that like you know
they didn't want him to be there and
there was you know all the politics
involved you know
were designed to sort of like you know
reduce the chances of somebody like him
being able to be there
but he was supposed to be there in the
sense that like you know he he won the
election and he
he's an emblematic of
of of what you can do in this country if
if you
put your mind to it and it's really not
like you know uh
see walled off for anybody any i mean
people can become president they can
they can they can
have that dream when they're younger and
they can they can they can do that
it's not a a royal thing
it's it's not a it's not an intellectual
thing
it's it's not there's no there's no uh
you know there's no uh proper
type of person
that should be that
and i think that what resonated with
people uh
with trump is that well first of all
there just wasn't
the options were what we had for the
past 30 years and we knew that that
wasn't working out we'd experienced 9 11
we experienced the
the housing market crash at the 2008
we'd seen occupy wall street we'd seen
all the things that basically
that side had done and they wanted to
continue their their reign essentially
by they you mean the democratic
establishment or the establishment
generally speaking the democratic
political establishment which
and i mean that includes the republican
side to the establishment you know i
mean i mean bush you know what i'm
talking about all the way
as far back i wouldn't even consider uh
george bush senior as being part of that
regime i would say
his son was
i'd say it started all with the clintons
the clintons really
um
when bill clinton uh
went into office i think he like
he did a re reshuffling of the deck
and really and that's where we've been
we i think a lot of the same people are
there
you you say you're very vocal and and
loud and supporting trump before so you
must have then experienced some sort of
pushback in the music industry or in the
creative industries the pushback wasn't
there and that's that's
that's what's that's what was so
alarming about it because
i think that the push back the pushback
might have been behind closed doors
there might have been
you know people talking like what is he
doing he's crazy or whatever i i don't
know i wasn't there
but um but at least to my face and
and as you know
it wouldn't have been
it wouldn't have been seen as a
prudent to like cancel them on those
grounds
just flat out i mean i but i think it
was enough of a
of an of an anachronism to have a
musician
coming out as pro-trump that like you
know there wasn't any kind of like
uh standard way of
of addressing that in
in a way uh publicly it's kind of
peculiar because
actually there's a lot of musicians who
are pro-trump that's an interesting it's
an interesting aspect of it because
because uh you know
everybody knows that like you know
nashville has had to uh
sort of uh
they've been had to be bedfellows with
hollywood uh entertainment industry you
know
and it's uh it's an uncomfortable
marriage you know
uh i think that like uh
the pop music world which is like you
know i would say
you know
tinseltown in hollywood
uh
it
operates
it sort of sort of like took over and
really kind of like you know
uh music [ __ ] music city usa in
nashville it was a
was really the the epicenter of country
and all that kind of stuff for for
a good part of the last century and then
it sort of just had to it sort of had to
it had to sort of join forces at some
point maybe around shania twain or
something i i don't know
where it was
or but probably before that it was
probably like a you know dolly parton or
something like that
but uh but that actually dolly parton is
a good good uh uh
a good person to because she's she was
an unconventional somebody that you know
probably wouldn't have made it in
nashville had just been nashville can
you take us through the experience of
what you lost having been at that trump
trump rally and what what were the
repercussions on your career as a
consequence of your attendance
and and then i'd like to ask about why
if you didn't attend the capitol hill
storming
what about your attendance of the rally
is so offensive or has been so offensive
is it simply support for trump
or is it
because they can't detach
attending the rally from capitol hill
well i lost my uh record deal right away
like just
right away
without any questions asked that's not a
big deal that would have been fine
um but they also um
not only did they drop me but it was it
was
is tempt them out to basically like
saying that i was there
and basically like these these these
these articles came out just claiming
that i was somewhere that i wasn't and
claiming that like
it didn't matter that i wasn't
there there
i mean they they didn't really care i
mean the the the media the the liberal
media was so in a
um
they're having their moment they really
they really wanted this to be
the linchpin to uh
to get trump and like basically make him
a holy
um
uh uh just a illegitimate from now on
they the goal was to basically be have
them not run in 224.
so they were they were they needed they
needed a uh
they needed a moment like this this is
kind of like a serendipitous wonderful
uh
stroke of good luck that that this
happened because this is this was the
thing that they could die and they could
use this that's why we're seeing the
hearings now
the media was so was prepared for that
too you know they were they were tipped
off they were all the cameras
and then on all the press were at the
capitol
prepared
for what was going to happen there the
rally
which had hundreds of thousands of
people
was not being covered really
i mean there was no cameras where i was
i thought and i admit to take a note
about that i was just like but that's
amazing and we're just walking around
here there's no
no uh uh uh
no
cnn buses no no journalists no nothing
like that no no coverage of it i mean
there's some that was up on the on the
bleachers
covering trump's uh speech a little bit
but i thought that that was that was uh
those are all but those weren't the
networks or anything like that
anyway um
but but they were there they were just a
mile away
and getting ready for the main event as
far as they were concerned because uh
that was
what they thought was the main event
it was whatever was going to happen at
congress
and you've explicitly condemned the
capital storming yourself or i've i've
read that you have absolutely
but but i also think that there's a
there's a
the
the idea that for instance
that trump
um
the big lie
you know this is what you hear about the
big lie that there was a election fraud
i mean this is what some people believe
now it could be wrong
but that's
in itself not a lie it's not it's not
he's not lying i believe that that trump
believed that there was some sort of
malfeasance in the election and i think
that the people whether he thought that
or not
i think the people feel that because
they were there they mean we we
experienced a
very strange uh uh uh
we were watching the elections as they
were taking place in real time we we we
thought that that was very strange that
there was a uh uh uh you know
that they that they
they stopped for the night you know
there's so many
so many areas where it really just
it just
we were just kind of like you know we
knew that like basically
uh uh we knew that something was really
really
screwy and there was being and then and
and this is something that's been
happening for four for four or five
years
ever since he took the he started the
campaign trail uh in 2015
and
and you know with the russia hoax which
has now been
proven to be a hoax i mean it's it's
it's pretty much
it's confirmed to be a hoax well further
than that it's it's one that uh that
links linked to hillary clinton to have
oh yeah yeah i wonder so so so so you
have to so that so
the point is is that like
we can understand why
other people would say
you know call foul on all these things
because they have something to lose and
because they're guilty of those things
and they're guilty of misleading the
people and they're guilty the media is
very very um has a lot of blood on their
hands
for being
so lo in lockstep with the democratic
party specifically
there's nothing wrong with me
being
pro-trump
never was and never should be any
anything wrong with people being
pro-trump there's nothing inherently you
might not like the guy i don't
necessarily like the guy
i don't need to have a guy that i like
in office
my life does not revolve around that but
that's my choice and i try and i and
being able to
to to say that you know to being able to
speak my mind has been has been my
career i mean that's that's expressing
myself is my job
that's what got me where i am if i if i
if i don't say what i what i it's on my
mind
then if i can't say if i have to like uh
you know censor myself uh
you know
beyond a certain beyond a
very very small degree i guess i mean i
i'd rather not even i just won't say
anything i won't even i won't bring sing
songs i won't
but scott what's what's
what i've
my career is sort of just you know what
i've been able to do is just
be myself for long enough and eventually
things
actually came around and started to like
you know
doors started to open for me
through it was through tenacity you know
it was a war of attrition between me and
the rest of the world but eventually
like you know
i i became
i did what i did and then i was i was
a store started to open because i
because of my commitment to it and it
was not an easy
and easiest sense so so
the fact that it it it came down so
quickly
on such spurious grounds
is
to me a uh
i mean it's it's it's it's offensive
it's certainly a phenomenon
to see so many artists experiencing
either being censored or self-censorship
to protect their careers
it's such a if any if any type of person
with any type of personality type or
traits
who are going to
hurt the most from
holding themselves back and not
expressing themselves it's the artist
and uh so it's particularly been curious
over the last couple years seeing that
it's other artists
silencing
artists artists don't censor other
artists i mean it's it's the the medium
you know we created the internet
to get around issues like censorship
that would come from top down from from
the
from from the government i mean we made
the internet
to
the the idea of the internet that the
whole thing is is is a
is against censorship it was a way to
get around those those uh those uh
obstacles you know of having to sort of
like you know deal with the industry
that was corrupt already and all this
kind of stuff
and the internet was this place where
you could do that and of course you know
that's that's a pipe dream and we knew
that it was going to be used uh you know
in you know in a bad way and you know
the more that you know it it sort of
the longer it was around but but
in principle it it really
it it sort of like you know embodies the
the the american dream in the in or you
know the west coast stream even you know
as liberal as they come you know i mean
this is this this place is was not
policed it was it was uh the internet
was a was a way to if they had a plan to
censor us that they they thought the
media was always on their side we had
this other plan and so
and so and and everything that's still
the idea more or less but now it's just
sort of like you know it's it's being
they're not even providing any kind of
uh they're not even having the
conversation they're just basically
speaking right past you they're not
listening
and uh uh you you can if they take you
down they just take you down they don't
need to explain it it's a fascistic it's
a weapon now it's a weapon now it's a
completely
evil weapon
ira the question that that i can't
answer in my head which i wonder if you
have insight to which is
if 74 million people voted for trump i.e
more than anyone who's ever run for
president with the exception of biden
which now that was 47
of roughly 47 of your country
that many people support trump
and you support trump how is it we're
basically half the country supported
trump that you have lost everything it
doesn't make sense to me
why have you faced that and not let's
say
uh john mouse who was with you then
as far as i can see that guy's
continuing with his music why why has it
come for ariel pink and unlike
anyone else well for one thing i was a
mark
i i think for for a while
prior i mean like i think that like you
know
i think that like you know i made it
made it known what my feelings were
about trump for for years
and so
that sort of uh
that sort of got everybody uh ready to
sort of like uh uh
put their their arrows in their quiver
and that and that kind of thing i mean
they were just
they were chomping at the bit
they probably had already you know in
behind closed doors but obviously like i
mean i think that like the people like
that that that run these
these uh these these tech platforms and
all these kinds of stuff and people that
like you know uh
uh
that that deal in in the uh you know
journalists or whatever i think that
there are these these conversations that
are had and uh and it seemed like you
know there's a sort of consensus that
like you know ariel is a trump supporter
you know he's an aerial you know the
discussion basically like had already
happened and so they they it didn't
surprise them they felt like you know oh
gotcha he's there he was there he's
there and i think that they had that
with john i don't think that i think
john was a surprise for them and i think
that they were just
they probably just thought i don't know
what the
think but but really it was as it had
it's just for the headlines mind you you
know i mean like they you know they
wanted to uh
they wanted to scandalize it they wanted
to make it a scandal they wanted to make
me they wanted to make
trump completely
uh illegitimate they wanted to make him
a terrorist they wanted to make trump
supporters of terrorists now how do they
do that
they did that by completely ignoring
the facts
you have to understand that there's like
this elitist class
and that includes journalism
and that includes uh there's like it's
like a strata of like uh that happens on
the
on in the cities and in the west coast
and in the east coast and then you know
in the cities
uh but it's but it's really this
this
gatekeeping class that is now aligned
with
with
with the left they don't have contact
and they do not listen to
i mean they they hate fox news they
think of it they've been it's been you
can read it in time time magazine you
could read what they think in newsweek
these articles explain it all i mean
they they they
throughout
trump's presidency they they were
they were really
pumping up the rhetoric to such a
and they were just saying you know you
can't be friends with your friends that
they're republican
it's it's time to like basically cut cut
cord we cannot support
anybody that we cannot support fascism
we could not support racism
as if they ever supported that before as
if anybody that like they were friends
with was a racist as if anybody as if
being a conservative or a trump
supporter ever meant that you were
racist prior to this never did you
wouldn't be friends with them if they
were but this is this was like a call
these were like direct these were like
maoist uh or like you know uh uh
uh
almost khmer rouge style
types of of uh of uh
of revolts they unleashed an
anti-federance you know i mean like i
mean it's this is a soros-style society
i'd say
you could definitely say there's a point
i was in the states for the trump
election uh in new york and before that
election trump was
posting saturday night live you could
have conversations about him and after
the election
it it was like he was a disease that
needed to be
you know cut out of the american body
what was what was what was more
outrageous was that the media probably
put him in the office i mean they
probably you know it was kind of like a
streisand effect or whatever like you
know where
they hated him so much
and they were so in unison i mean this
and before he became president you know
fox
was just as outraged by him there was
you couldn't say that like anybody
was really on his side on in the media
outwardly
he didn't have him and even the
conservatives you know like i mean they
were
so
but but what they were doing
was not telling the the news they were
not giving us the facts i mean to a
certain degree they couldn't avoid the
fact that like you know he was still in
the running with hillary
all the way to the very end but but keep
in mind the entire time they're saying
that
they're saying there's no way he can win
and the polls show that
and
that's why it was even julian assange
was saying he would
you know if trump won he would you know
he would he would personally like you
know he would turn himself in
he was saying that thinking that like
you know there's no way that trump would
win
i mean so everybody was convinced that
trump wouldn't win so that when he won
it was kind of a complete travesty and
that's because
the
the news
and and journalism in general was
completely
was shown to be of complete
forest it was it was bought and paid for
by the democratic party it was a
complete it was shown the whole thing
was basically unmasked in the campaign
and they run up to his election and
that's what was shocking
it was was that like that the news could
tell you that
he was there's no way that he could win
that every single poll said that every
single poll said that he wouldn't win
that everybody was that there was no way
that he could win and that hillary this
was like a this was like a done deal
and so it was a com you know and i was
just you know somebody who was
didn't have a state you know didn't have
skin in that game and was just like
watching and i was just like they're
gonna they're gonna give him the
they're gonna give him the presidency
just by talking about him this much i
mean if they wanted to get rid of him
they could have just given him the the
bernie sanders treatment and not covered
him so now in biden's america what's
that what's the atmosphere has it has it
calmed now that or
is there a fear that time will return i
guess we're in the middle of the uh
january 6th hearings right now what
what's it like for you out in california
well for me i mean it's it's it's been
it's been an ongoing thing and it's
obviously been like it's been sort of
like uh it feels like it's a
yeah i've got like a pain in my chest
you know every day because
because of the
the trauma i guess
i can't attend concerts i can't attend
i can't go to to bars i can't go to
certain places okay so anywhere that i'm
recognized really
i can't go to restaurants because
the employees don't feel safe
that's what the managers will tell me
and what ground can they have anyone
elaborated on there's no elaboration on
it it's it's it's fascistic i mean it's
a totalitarian thing everybody's taking
this is the thing nobody wants to get
there nobody wants to be the one to just
to ruffle you know everybody's basically
trying to uh avoid uh a scandal
they don't want to have to like uh uh
lose uh
lose followers or lose customers
and that's that for them it's a business
deal it's it's it's that's their excuse
is that it's a you know it's kind of
like the same the same mentality that's
that's uh
you know
having all these companies go woke and
and and the sustainability esg stuff you
know what i'm saying it's it's all this
stuff that uh
all these uh
sustainability and diversity equity
inclusion all that stuff is like has
just been
you know swallowed hook line and synchro
here and especially in la
this is a shocking portrait of modern
america that you're painting
for supporting a presidential candidate
who got 47 of the vote you are not only
lost
a hell of a lot of work but your your
blacklisted from even going to
bars and venues in your hometown my
friends will invite me you know you know
a few people i still have people that
you know
still talk to me of course you know and
and and in secret they'll say you know
of course i don't care about that stuff
you know and they have a show
and they invite me
to perform even
and or like you know make an appearance
on stage do something and uh
and i'm like well
maybe you want to check with the uh with
the venue first and they're like they're
like
okay i mean we can you know like maybe
we'll bring you in with the crew or
something like that i'm like well you
might want to check with the venue i
don't want to i don't want to be put in
that position personally i don't want
you to be put in that position it's just
kind of humiliating for me because i
this i'm so used to this
and then they they
they text their you know the owners and
whatever and then
the owners get back and they're just
like
uh
yeah we're gonna have to say no and
anybody specifically done that zebulon
in la um
salazar restaurant
um
uh
basically anybody if anybody that we ask
anybody that i ask and now i always i
don't wanna i don't want people
basically sneaking me in
behind the scenes
i don't wanna do that that's not that's
not what but i don't wanna have to
tiptoe
i wanna go somewhere
where i'm gonna
where i have you know the right to stay
there and i don't wanna and i wanna be
just a a
irregular uh uh uh
person there and i don't wanna go there
and discover that like you know
somebody's complaining somebody
complained and i had to leave that's
that's not what i'm about and i don't
want to put i don't i don't it's not fun
for me
i want to be supported
what about your music are you able to
carry on no
i can't get concerts i cannot i mean i'm
i'm i am so cancelled
and nobody cares but that's fine i mean
that's i mean it's it's it's you know
what was me i think a lot of people care
i think a lot of people are shocked by
it well no but but you know what what
what is it
nobody nobody cares that much nobody
cares enough to put their own ass on the
line for it
that's what it comes down to and i think
that like uh
i think that's the the weird
you know the conundrum is that you know
i wouldn't uh
i wouldn't have gone if i didn't feel
some some some
sense of urgency about it i wouldn't
have voted for trump if i didn't think
that it was like completely crucial
and um
i mean it was just because i saw what
was already happening
to my friends and the democratic party
and to like the people that i know and i
saw what was going i saw their their
mentality they were just so
and i said you know what
even if these people wanted to
not vote for biden they they were
they
they couldn't say that
they couldn't say it out loud
there's nobody in hollywood that's
coming out and saying they're pro
uh a trump they can't do that
that's weird
you know i should be able to like you
know vote for trump even you know for my
own reasons just because like hey i'm
just some just because i
because i don't care
just because it was a joke even you know
it doesn't my reasons it doesn't matter
but people people have that right they
shouldn't be
they shouldn't be punished for it
if i lose the election
that's the consequence
you don't get you don't get to punish me
if i'm the loser
you don't get to um if if alex jones is
wrong about sandy hook
that doesn't mean you sue him
for harming for for the for the for for
other people uh
you know making making more of it than
is necessary and and and making other
people's lives miserable
i don't care what what i mean
people have individual
uh autonomy
they're responsible for their own
actions they should be they should be
held
there's not it's not the world is not
just a bunch of cult leaders one of the
other um attendees with you was alex lee
moyer the director of alex's war the
film
about alex's jones he said me and
hillary are demonstrating
alex jones is uh probably the most
censored person in america he's
banned from
twitter youtube every social media
platform
and this film
and and the director um alex has managed
to
nonetheless get this film about him up i
think at the moment as time of
us speaking it's number two in the
itunes
pre-sale charts something like that very
high and
so
where you were censored and how
everything stripped up this other person
who was
you know with you on that days is facing
uh into the cancellation cancellation
and and
piercing piercing through it what do you
account that difference
is it a mentality difference is it
because film is different from
music
she's a director
and i think that like you know there
she's uh
her opinions are are
you know
sort of
you know i don't think it really has i
mean she's she's getting a lot of
a lot of flack for it i mean just just
for for doing it
you know this because of the subject
matter and then people think that it's
one of the same thing but i think that
that there is you know among
among other circles
and i'm speaking in the corporate world
um
they don't they they know that like you
know that that that uh
she is she's not the uh necessarily the
the subject of her film
and she can she can uh she can sort of
dodge that uh
mommy she's not
i think that she's she's she's
she's been canceled she's had a lot of
flack for it and i think that like you
know she's not necessarily necessarily a
conservative she was not necessarily a
trump supporter
she was just making a movie about alice
jones you know and she doesn't
necessarily condone what alex jones
says or
or stands for
neither neither do i i mean not not
everything he says i don't i don't i
don't support everything he says either
but that's the point is that like
the that that that distinction is just
seems to be lost uh among the greater
the younger population at least or like
the people that are like woken you know
doling out consequences for people's
actions and and doing all this social
justice stuff um i think with the i
can't speak for mouse but i think that
like a lot of it is uh
is just fear you know i mean i haven't
heard what he's uh what he's he hasn't
really been public since since the whole
i haven't really talked to him since
then i mean even even trump supporters
cancelled hands with me
in a sense why the trump supporters
can't see you well i'm just saying like
you know i haven't spoken to john we've
just been like we we went separate i
think
i mean i'm just saying it it's it's it's
more than
the uh the opinions and and canceling is
more than
whatever that people say it is i mean
it's it's it's just it's in it's an
about face and ultimately that about
face was
only
only
and solely uh
by the media i mean like the media
basically
made me
the message went out i was not allowed
anymore and everybody that liked me
had to basically make uh make a show of
disavowing me in order to gain
any kind of uh
in order to still stay in their friend
group and in order to stay uh
in order to not invite the wrath that i
incurred you know because that was just
that was just the trump the trump stink
that i got on me
and trump and then nobody wants the
trump stink because you'll be you'll be
taken down by association there this is
this was a a hit job this is they're
going after
the person and now that he was out
i was just the first casualty or one of
them i mean but alex was really the
first casualty of this even before trump
you are still making music and um
i hope that you find
an outlet for that and i know your many
fans
and i do believe you still have many
fans will will
eagerly anticipate
new music what can we look forward to
from you
a lot more of me
yeah unfortunately they're gonna they're
gonna have to kill me if they uh
they didn't kill me that's unfortunately
so so uh and there's not much left for
me to do i mean i i but complain about
the stuff online
so
uh you know if you guys uh if
a little message to the uh to the world
out there i could be making music and
shutting up about all this stuff uh if
you uncancel me but i don't think that's
gonna happen
about like coming on the show
well ariel thank you so much for your
time and for talking to me and i look
forward to hearing your music when um
you're releasing okay thank you
that was fun bye winston
[Music]
you